.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Wenn mal alle an einem Tisch sitzen
und ich am Schluss sage:
"Ich mache die Bauleitung
und wäre froh,
wenn alles über mich laufen würde",
gibt es jeweils Reaktionen wie:
"Ah, okay, Sie machen
die Bauleitung. Gut. Tough."
Die Baustelle: ein Ort, wo die
reine Muskelkraft noch etwas zählt,
wo Frauen nachgepfiffen wird und
der Umgang untereinander ruppig ist.
In dieser männlich geprägten Branche
fühlt sich Katrin Bachmann wohl.
Die 27-jährige St. Gallerin
ist Bauleiterin
und hat auf mehreren
grossen Baustellen das Sagen.
Wie sie sich in dieser
männerdominierten Umgebung behauptet
und sich Respekt verschafft,
davon handelt dieser Film.
Morgens stehe ich meist
zwischen 5 und 5.30 Uhr auf.
Duschen, bereit machen,
ich sollte Frühstück mitnehmen,
wenn ich Zeit habe.
Es ist einfach so:
ab 7 Uhr klingelt das Telefon.
Ab 7 Uhr sind die Leute
auf der Baustelle,
dann muss man erreichbar sein.
Als Bauleiterin ist Katrin Bachmann
täglich auf Baustellen unterwegs.
Sie koordiniert und kontrolliert
die Arbeiten aller beteiligten
Unternehmen und Handwerker,
hat Budget und Termine im Überblick.
Hier in Zürich an der Claridenstrasse
wird ein Bürogebäude
umgebaut und neu gestaltet.
Ich hätte es da gerne etwas höher.
Manchmal bin ich
zwar nicht gerade ein Polizist,
aber jemand, der alle
daran erinnert, was noch zu tun ist.
"Hier fehlt noch etwas
und dort musst du auch noch ran."
Rund 40 Leute
arbeiten zurzeit auf diesem Platz,
mit Ausnahme einer Architektin
alles Männer.
Ich treffe selten Frauen an.
Pro Baustelle gibt es je nach Grösse
vielleicht ein bis zwei Frauen.
Ich traf schon Malerinnen
oder Sanitärinstallateurinnen an.
Und auf der letzten Baustelle
traf ich eine Elektrikerin an.
In der Planung sind mehr Frauen.
Da begegnete ich einer Elektro-
planerin, einer Brandschutzplanerin.
Da ist die Verbreitung von Frauen
grösser
als unter den handwerklichen Jobs
auf der Baustelle.
Wir müssen ein Geschoss tiefer
steigen.
Als seltene Spezies auf der Baustelle
löst Katrin Bachmann
gerade zu Beginn eines Projektes
unterschiedliche Reaktionen aus.
Eine Frau - das ist
immer etwas Eigenartiges.
V.a. für Männer ist eine Frau
auf der Baustelle überraschend.
Die einen Männer
freuen sich darüber,
andere Männer fragen sich:
"Was will uns die jetzt sagen?"
Aber eben, ich kriege es selber mit,
wie sich die einen
über eine Frau freuen,
die die Stimmung auflockert.
Es ist jedenfalls
anders als gewöhnlich.
So gesehen passt es.
Wegen der Rundungen
bei diesen Vorhangschienen,
dafür hat mir bis jetzt
noch niemand unterschrieben.
Ist gut, ja.
- Vielen Dank.
Bitte, gern geschehen.
- Madame, Ihnen einen schönen Tag.
Tschüss
- Tschau.
Das wird schwierig. Soll ich
ein Stück der Fliesen rausnehmen?
Es bleibt nichts anderes übrig,
als sie gerade zu setzen.
Ein Mann ist netter zu einer Frau
als einem Mann gegenüber.
Man merkt, dass die Leute zu einer
Frau netter sind als zu einem Mann.
Da musst du einen Anzug machen.
Ist gut?
Aber hier warten wir zu,
dafür habe ich jetzt keine Zeit.
Als Frau,
dazu noch jung und mit 1,55 m
nicht gerade eine grosse Erscheinung,
fühlt sie sich
nicht immer ernst genommen.
Es treten immer wieder Situationen
auf, in denen Männer sagen:
"Schwatz du nur."
"Ich mache, wann ich will,
wann ich Zeit und Lust habe."
Manchmal wollen diese Männer
zwar nicht den Chef markieren,
aber das Alpha-Tierchen zeigen.
Das ist typisch Mann.
Das tragen die Männer
eben so in sich.
Hallo miteinander.
Anders als ein Mann
in derselben Position
müsse sie als Frau immer wieder
beweisen, dass sie kompetent sei.
Das Fachwissen ist das Gebiet,
in das sich die Männer zurückziehen.
Als Frau ist das Fachwissen
der wunde Punkt:
"Sie kann das nicht.
Sie bringt das nicht zustande."
Es ist zwar hart
und nicht wirklich fair,
aber so ist es eben.
Auf irgendeinem Gebiet müssen sie
uns eben prüfen und testen.
Hallo miteinander, ich begrüsse euch
zur Bauteamsitzung 43.
Meine Herren, bitte! Danke.
Gibt es irgendwelche Anmerkungen
zum letzten Protokoll?
Ich muss präsent sein,
muss zeigen, dass ich hier bin.
Sie müssen mir zuhören,
auch während der Sitzung.
Wenn sie beginnen, miteinander
zu schwatzen, unterbreche ich.
Wenn jemand zurückhaltend reagiert,
befürchte ich ein drohendes Chaos.
Ich muss den roten Faden vorgeben,
muss das Protokoll und die Termine
im Überblick behalten.
Das Wissen reicht nicht, ich muss es
präsentieren und formulieren können.
Bitte fragt bei Problemen nach.
Ja, das tun wir.
Mein Herr, hallo.
Hier drin wird nicht geraucht.
Dort darfst du rauchen.
Jetzt aber raus!
Der Strom ist schon eingeschaltet.
Ganz selten komme es vor,
dass sie als Bauleiterin
nicht akzeptiert werde.
Es gab schon Situationen,
in denen ein Unternehmen sagte:
"Von Ihnen lasse ich mir
nichts vorschreiben."
Ich antwortete:
"Wenn Sie damit ein Problem haben,
wenden Sie sich bitte
an meinen Chef."
Mein Chef reagierte gelassen,
rief an und sagte:
"Frau Bachmann hat die Bauleitung
inne, ob es Ihnen passt oder nicht."
"Schicken Sie bitte Ersatz,
wenn es Ihnen nicht passt."
Meine Herren, Sie haben hier
eine ziemliche Unordnung.
Was für eine Unordnung!
Die gelernte Hochbauzeichnerin
arbeitet bei der Firma Ghisleni.
55 % der Mitarbeitenden
des Unternehmens sind Frauen,
wobei die meisten nicht regelmässig
auf die Baustellen gehen.
Die Frage,
ob es Katrin Bachmann als Frau
auf einer Baustelle schwerer habe
als ein Mann,
löst eine Diskussion
mit dem Geschäftsinhaber aus.
Also ich habe eine klare Haltung:
Nein.
Nein? Warum?
Du besitzt eine
grosse Durchsetzungskraft.
Und so, wie du aufgewachsen bist,
und aus deinem Familienhintergrund,
bist du dir die Sprache und
den Umgang auf Baustellen gewohnt.
Du kannst mit Leuten
auf verschiedenen Ebenen reden.
Deshalb antworte ich dezidiert:
Nein.
Aber der Auftritt einer Frau
zeigt bei Männern die Wirkung,
dass sie sich auf eine andere
Art und Weise beweisen wollen,
anders als beim Auftritt
eines männlichen Bauleiters.
Ich bin überrascht,
dass du das sagst.
Manchmal spüre ich das etwas.
Ich muss mich oft wiederholen, damit
Arbeiten richtig ausgeführt werden.
Frau wie Mann,
beide müssen sich in ihrem Umfeld
und Berufsfeld beweisen können.
Dafür gibt es irgendwie keine ...
Das stimmt, aber im Hinterkopf
lauern Fragen wie:
"Verfügt sie
über das nötige Fachwissen?"
Wenn sie meinen Hintergrund kennen,
dann wird ihnen schnell klar:
"Aha, sie kommt vom Bau. Sie stammt
aus einer Baumeisterfamilie."
Dann entschärft sich
die Situation etwas.
Aber das geht mir genauso.
Wenn ich erwähne,
dass mein Vater Polier war,
dass mein Onkel und viele Verwandte
Maurer waren,
dann schafft das eine Nähe,
eine Beziehung.
Es ist entscheidend,
dass man sich selber bleibt.
Alle Menschen wollen
respektvoll behandelt werden.
Genau, dann spielt es keine Rolle,
ob es ein Mann oder eine Frau ist.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich fand die Baubranche schon immer
attraktiv wegen meiner Familie.
Mein Vater ist Baumeister.
Darum bestand schon früh
ein Bezug zum Baugewerbe.
Wir durften oft
mitgehen auf Baustellen.
Während der Sommerferien nahm mein
Vater uns mit, erklärte uns alles,
und wir durften Bagger fahren.
Die Baubranche
hat mich schon immer fasziniert.
Katrin Bachmann trifft sich
zum Abendessen mit der Familie.
Hallo.
Vater Bruno Bachmann
hat ein Baumeistergeschäft.
Die beiden jüngeren Brüder
sind als Maurer und Bauführer
ebenfalls in der Branche tätig.
Es wäre naheliegend
für Katrin Bachmann,
ins Familienunternehmen einzusteigen,
doch bietet der Vater
keine Bauleitung an.
Vorbehalte der eigenen Tochter
gegenüber seien keine da.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Mein Vater hat mir dieses Vertrauen
schon immer geschenkt.
Und ich denke, er weiss,
dass ich meinen Job gut mache.
Wir durften schon zwei,
drei Aufträge für ihn ausführen.
Deshalb hätte er keine Bedenken,
wenn ich mich entscheiden würde:
"Ich würde gerne einsteigen und es
mit meinen Brüdern übernehmen."
Dort brauchst du keine Toilette.
Wenn es eine schaffe,
sich auf dem Bau zu behaupten,
dann sei es seine Tochter.
Es besteht
die Gefahr oder das Risiko,
als Frau im Baugewerbe unterzugehen,
weil es auf der Baustelle
oft ruppig zu und her geht.
Dort herrscht
ein harter und rauer Umgangston.
Aber weil man Katrin kennt,
weil man auch mich sehr gut kennt,
wissen viele, dass wir
die Ellbogen einsetzen können.
Sie ist nicht vorlaut, kann aber
wenn nötig ihre Meinung geigen.
Sie kann auch zickig tun,
aber das sollte man auf dem Bau
tunlichst vermeiden,
dort muss man den Mann stellen.
Selbst ich muss oft meine Ellbogen
ausfahren, um mich durchzusetzen.
Für dich als Frau
ist es noch viel schwieriger,
weil sich die Bauarbeiter denken:
"Was will die uns vorschreiben?"
Das muss man
an sich abperlen lassen.
Bei dummen Sprüchen
auf Durchzug stellen,
Ellbogen einsetzen
und sich durchsetzen.
Das hat Katrin Bachmann mit ihren
beiden Brüdern schon früh gelernt.
Ich bin eigentlich
positiv überrascht,
dass sie es
so weit gebracht hat bis jetzt.
He! Hallo? Was?
Ich habe noch nie eine
grobe Diskriminierung von Frauen
im Baugewerbe beobachtet.
Wenn sich Frauen
in diese Branche wagen,
dann suchen sie vielleicht
auch etwas den Kontrast,
suchen einen Ort,
wo sie sich beweisen können,
wo sie zeigen können,
dass sie es auch drauf haben.
Schau! Ich werde umringt
von schwarzen Kindern.
Hier küsse ich ein Kind, wie süss.
Bin ich das?
- Ja, sicher.
Das bist auch du.
Einen grossen Teil ihrer Kindheit
verbrachte sie in Afrika.
Der Vater hat in Tansania
ein Kloster und Wasserwerke gebaut.
Die Familie war
fast neun Jahre lang mit ihm dort.
Wir sind ganz anders aufgewachsen,
auch sehr einfach.
Wir spielten mit Lehm,
den unser Vater
von der Baustelle mitgebracht hatte.
Wir schufen damit Figuren.
Das sind Eindrücke und Erinnerungen,
die prägen,
die ich auch nicht missen möchte.
Schon damals wollte sie auf den Bau,
darum hat sie sich
die grossen Schuhe angezogen.
Ich wollte mitarbeiten.
- Das war lustig.
Die Denkweise beeinflusst stark die
Herangehensweise an gewisse Dinge.
Wenn jemand sagt:
"Nein, das geht nicht",
muss man sagen:
"Doch, das funktioniert schon."
"Lass es uns
von einer anderen Seite betrachten."
Wenn in Afrika
etwas nicht möglich war,
weil zum Beispiel
kein Kran verfügbar war,
suchte man nach einer Lösung,
mit der es trotzdem funktionierte.
Ich zehre noch immer
von diesen Zeiten.
Wenn ich hier auf Probleme stosse,
denke ich: "In Afrika haben wir
alles irgendwie geschafft."
Das war diese schöne Lockerheit,
die mir wirklich
noch immer sehr viel wert ist.
Die zweite Grossbaustelle, die Katrin
Bachmann als Bauleiterin betreut.
Am Kreuzplatz in Zürich entsteht
ein Gebäude mit acht Geschossen
für einen Supermarkt,
ein Fitnessstudio und Büros.
Die Faszination für Baustellen
hat seit ihrer Kindheit
nicht nachgelassen.
Jeder Tag ist anders.
Man sieht, wie es vorwärts geht.
Wenn man etwas vereinbart hat,
ein Detailproblem gelöst hat,
sieht man, dass es funktioniert,
dass es hält.
Es ist spannend, einen Bau
nicht nur auf Plänen zu sehen,
sondern mittendrin zu stehen,
wo nachher die Garage,
die Kühlzelle,
die Aufbereitung stehen werden.
Man sieht,
wie die Sachen ihre Form annehmen.
Hast du gesehen,
dass die von der Stadt Zürich
die Ecke eingemessen haben?
Die ist gut.
Betonierst du die Decke hier morgen?
Ja, die mache ich morgen.
Auf der Baustelle ist der Polier,
allen bekannt als Pipo,
der wichtigste Ansprechpartner
für die Bauleiterin.
Gehen wir hoch.
Der Portugiese gibt zu:
Auf dem Bau freut man sich,
wenn eine Frau aufkreuzt.
Es gibt nicht so viele Frauen
auf Baustellen.
Und Männer schauen
immer den Frauen nach.
Ich treffe es immer wieder an, dass
ich solche Bilder von Frauen sehe.
Ich als Frau muss sagen,
dass es für mich in Ordnung geht,
wenn es schöne Bilder sind.
Sie hängen die Bilder auf,
weil sie Freude daran haben.
Pro Tag betrachten sie das Bild
vielleicht eine halbe Stunde
oder was auch immer,
vielleicht höchstens.
So gesehen
ist das für mich kein Problem,
denn draussen
erledigen sie ihren Job.
Katrin Bachmann ist da tolerant,
auch was die nackten Oberkörper
auf dem Bau angeht.
Im Sommer gibt es davon viele
zu sehen, ob frau will oder nicht.
Die Akzeptanz oder die Schwelle
von nackten Oberkörpern bei Männern
ist völlig anders gelagert
als bei Frauen.
Wenn eine Frau in einem Minirock
auf die Baustelle kommt,
wie wir vorher gehört haben,
haben die Männer einfach Freude.
Nicht, dass sie die Frau
nicht mehr ernst nehmen,
aber es besteht in solchen Fällen
eine völlig andere Wirkung.
Ich achte darauf,
immer lange Hosen zu tragen,
auch als Schutz, wenn ich
z.B mit Metallwaren zu tun habe.
Auch bei der Oberbekleidung
achte ich darauf,
dass keine nackten Körperstellen
zu sehen sind,
sonst heisst es dann wieder
unter den Männern:
"Schau dir die an,
wie knapp bekleidet sie ist!"
"Da sieht man etwas
von ihrer nackten Haut."
Als Frau muss man sich bewusst sein,
dass Männer dann sofort hinschauen.
Eine Frau müsse sich
eben anpassen an diese raue Welt,
da werde einem nichts geschenkt.
Wenn du als Frau
auf einer Baustelle arbeitest,
darfst du keine Spezialbehandlung
erwarten.
Dann musst du dich
darauf einstellen.
Ich weiss bereits morgens, welche
Arbeiten es heute zu erledigen gilt,
bei denen zehn Männer
um mich herum sind.
Deshalb bin ich der Meinung,
dass es unmöglich ist,
eine Baustelle
frauenfreundlicher zu gestalten.
Ich denke nicht
oder wüsste nicht, wie.
Vielleicht mit der Vereinbarkeit
von Familie und Beruf?
Katrin Bachmann
stellt sich in Zukunft
ein Leben mit Partner und Kindern
in einer Wohnung vor,
die sie übrigens selbst gezeichnet
und zusammen mit ihrem Vater
gebaut hat.
Für diesen Traum würde sie
auch beruflich zurückstecken.
Ihren jetzigen Job
könne sie mit einem Teilzeitpensum
wohl nicht machen, meint sie.
Die tägliche Präsenz
auf einer Grossbaustelle
wäre dann
wahrscheinlich nicht möglich.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
kleinere Bauprojekte zu betreuen.
Oder ich wechsle zur Projektleitung.
Da gibt es Jobs,
die man problemlos auch mit einem
60-%-Teilzeitpensum abdecken kann.
Das würde mir auch passen, weil ich
das vorher auch schon gemacht habe.
Teilt euch in Zweiergruppen auf!
Du zu Etienne!
Abends auf dem Fussballplatz
tanzt ein Dutzend Buben
nach Katrin Bachmanns Pfeife.
Es hat sich durch meine Brüder
und Kollegen so ergeben,
dass ich da reingerutscht bin.
Mein Bruder und meine Kollegen
spielen ebenfalls Fussball.
Hier kann ich mich einbringen
und finde es toll.
Drin ist drin, Marco!
Marco, mit Innenrist!
Ich kann besser
mit Männern umgehen als mit Frauen.
Ich habe auch
mehr Freunde als Freundinnen,
weil für mich
Männer etwas einfacher sind.
Ich mag das Gezicke unter Frauen
einfach nicht.
Kommt hinter die Linie!
Baustelle Claridenstrasse.
Die Bauleiterin macht
eine der letzten Kontrollen,
bevor das Objekt
der Bauherrschaft übergeben wird.
Morgen.
- Morgen.
Ich wäre froh, wenn es wenigstens
nur eine Delle hätte und nicht drei,
hier sind es zwei.
- Zwei sind das Maximum.
Aber das ist sichtbar,
das sieht man.
Das ist so.
Mir fallen solche Sachen auf.
Ich will, dass es perfekt ist, dass
es aufs Penibelste ausgeführt wird.
Das ist auch der Anspruch,
den die Architekten
und die Bauherrschaft haben.
Ich will ihnen ein möglichst
perfektes Objekt übergeben.
An diesem Morgen
wird die Geduld der Bauleiterin
noch einmal auf die Probe gestellt.
Was ist schräg?
Das klären wir gerade ab.
- Alles.
Auch das Blech ist schräg.
Dieser Spalt hier
ist grösser als jener dort.
Irgendwie ist deine Türe schräg.
Ja.
Das ist ganz bestimmt möglich,
denn hier ist ein Spalt,
der sich von 1 cm auf 3 cm weitet.
Es nervt, dass ich kurz vor Schluss
noch solche Sachen entdecken muss.
Aber jetzt müssen wir
schnell nach einer Lösung suchen
und hoffen, dass wir herausfinden,
woran es liegt.
Ich hoffe, es ist bloss ein Blech,
das wir etwas schieben können.
Nein,
die Tür kann nicht schräg sein.
In solchen Momenten
muss ich der ruhende Pol sein.
Wenn ich dann
auch noch beginnen würde,
mich aufbrausend zu verhalten,
dann würde sich das hochschaukeln.
Das Blech ist gerade,
der Stein ist leicht schräg.
Leicht schräg.
- Ja.
Das Gefühl kurz vor Bauabgabe
ist toll.
Man sieht, wie es fertig wird.
Man sieht auch,
was alles geleistet wurde.
All die Anstrengungen, all die
Diskussionen, die man geführt hat,
haben wirklich
zu einem Ziel geführt.
Wir haben dieses Gebäude
gemeinsam erschaffen.
Mit ihrer unkomplizierten,
pragmatischen Art,
einer guten Portion
Humor und Gelassenheit
setzt sich Katrin Bachmann
in dieser Männerwelt durch.
Und solange sie Spass
an der Arbeit habe,
werde sie der Branche
weiter treu bleiben.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2020